you just did the 40 by 40 campaign with  meghan markle which was pretty cool was  that like doing that  just amazing i'm impressed and inspired  by her i love someone who chooses to  lead their life the way they want to and  give their children the life that they  they want to give them and then to take  an opportunity where you know it's her  40th maybe like what what fun thing does  she want and instead she's like how can  i get more people to help other women  that need help i was like that's that's  what we need we need a billion more  people like that in the world to do that  to be like take a little bit of time  that you can really help somebody she's  like that that's how i would like to  celebrate my 40th and i was like  sign me up how do you not want to do  that